do you have experience with people
telling you that you're too intense or
that you need to work on not being so
upfront and straightforward sometimes
it's called working on your how I think
it would be great to hear how you could
apply this using extreme ownership in
the business world there is a big push
on diversity which is wonderful but
often it comes with also data
diversifying away from intensity and
male aggression quote unquote
I'd love your thoughts well this is it's
kind of interesting to hit this question
it's kind of strange to get this
question because all the time when I
talk about leadership I talk about how
often do you hear me say take the
indirect approach to something mm-hmm I
always talk about the indirect approach
because the direct approach is is not
jujitsu the direct approach is beating
your head and punching someone in the
face mm-hmm
so I'm always talking about using the
indirect approach so by its very nature
indirect is not straightforward right
it's not intense yeah so no I don't have
people telling me I'm too intense or I'm
too straightforward why don't I have
them telling me that because I'm not I'm
not and I'm not saying that I'm not
intense I'm not saying that I'm not
straightforward but I'm very very
careful not to go too far with either
this is this is like a fighter that's
swinging too hard or being too
predictable or just will stand and trade
and take damage and do damage that's the
direct approach the direct approach is I
punch you in the face and you punch me
in the face and we play a war of
attrition I don't want to enter into a
war of attrition I do not want to enter
into a war of attrition I want to use a
maneuver warfare I want to
move I want to slip unseen into the weak
areas and set my bombs and have them go
off so I just got this Asus the other
night by a relatively new client of mine
you know are you gonna get in their
faces and in getting the faces of the
leadership and tell them straight up
that they need to get their act together
you could see that this person was very
excited by that idea and it was one of
the senior leaders and uh you know how
was that you had this idea that also to
come in and just get in their faces and
tell them how screwed up they were and I
said no I likely will not do that and
then I said to him I said look what if I
told you that you were all screwed up
and you're a failure at your job and you
do you're a weak leader what would you
then be feel like you really wanted to
listen to me would you would you be open
to my suggestions at that point do you
think I'd be an efficient coach do you
think I would even appear as an
intelligent human being if the best I
could do to coach you was to tell you
that you sucked as a leader and you were
a failure your job and you're screwing
everything up and I we see the answers
were no no no of course not I would be a
horrible coach I would be a horrible
leader myself if that's what I resorted
to and most importantly if I want you to
change and the way I'm trying to get you
to train is by change is by being
abusive and begging you to send up your
defenses and not listen to me what the
hell good am i doing why would I do
anything that's going to inhibit my goal
which my goal is to get you to change it
should be a better leader so if I slap
you in the face
with aggression oh it's
straightforwardness that makes you
defensive how does that help me the
answer is it doesn't now again that
doesn't mean that I'm never
straightforward and then I'm never
aggressive but I calculate those moments
I calculate those moments there's a
reason why we sugarcoat medicine for
little children right there is why is it
so they take it it's so they take it
into their system and it's the same
thing with adults and people say don't
sugarcoat it don't you don't just tell
me how it is they don't mean it they
want it sugar-coated because they want
to accept it into their body it's just
like jiu-jitsu you need to use jiu-jitsu
you need to set things up you need to
manipulate to get people to do what you
want to do especially if it has to do
with them changing themselves one of the
worst ways to get someone to change is
by telling him exactly how you want them
to change I mean of course their
situation we have this beautiful
relationship and you've built it with
someone you have this intimate trust
with another human being I don't think I
have that with anybody but there have
been situations in my life where I've
had oh just complete utter trust with
you know maybe there's three or four
people that I have that with in my whole
life that I can just say listen man
here's the deal don't get defensive
here's what's going on here's what you
need to adjust very few people do you
have that relationship in life so you
gotta use that
nuance and that maneuver warfare and
it's the same thing with aggression it's
the same thing that this we just read in
this article don't yell at the Chechen
people you're not gonna be able to get
what you want from them and like I said
it doesn't just apply to those people it
applies to all people you gotta bring
people in and you gotta manipulate them
and I know that again that has negative
connotations but it's what you're doing
you're trying to get someone to think a
different way that's manipulation you
can call it influence you can call
whatever you want but that's what you're
trying to do and the most difficult way
to manipulate someone is to slap them in
the face with aggression so there's a
little dichotomy here of course because
you know I always say the default mode
has to be aggressive but I don't mean
necessarily overtly aggressive it means
that you're aggressively forcing things
to go in your direction through every
means necessary through overt and covert
and clandestine and honestly the
preferred method of all is covert the
preferred method for me to get echo to
do something different is for echo to
never even think I had an opinion on it
is for me just to sneak in there behind
enemy lines plant the seeds and let them
grow and let echo come to the conclusion
that you're gonna change the way you're
doing something you can do a think
differently about something that's
leadership that's real leadership so
that's what you got to work on if
somebody is telling you you're too
intense and you too aggressive guess
what you are you're giving away your
greatest weapon
you're advertising your attack surprise
is one of the most key components in a
battle and when you tell people
aggressively and overtly what you're
doing you're giving up that element
don't do it I'm asking you not to be a
manipulative person behind the scenes
with weird plans but that is what I'm
asking you to do that is what I'm asking
you to do because that is how you get
things done that is how you get into
people's minds that is how you lead not
by yelling not by being overly
aggressive not by being so intense that
people don't want to listen to you
because intensity is a form of emotion
right and the minute you come across as
an emotional intense maniac
people are questioning already your
validity those guys are too intense mmm
don't be that guy
manipulate influence be clandestine and
covert and that is how you win the
reason that I was kind of laughing was
reading this question is that it kind of
makes sense from someone kind of from
the outside and the only and the main
times when me personally were out view
you as being intense or aggressive or or
is like when you're just talking about
something now you're never doing it
towards anybody you know like you'll
never lose it I've never then
I've known you since Oh 6 I think
something like that yeah and I've never
seen you lose your temper get mad
I mean kind of it one time um it's funny
I was talking to Lafe about it no we've
never really seen you get mad but maybe
one or two times you have this
aggressive and intense persona for sure
and when you talk about things for sure
but yeah when you're dealing with people
it it's real like basically the way
you'd want to be engaged with another
human yeah yeah yeah just wants to have
somebody get aggressive with him it's
never it never the only time it works
like if you're handling a prisoner like
literally if I'm handling a prisoner
I'll be aggressive with them yeah if I'm
trying to get command of a of a of a
chaotic situation and there's a there's
another aggressor in the situation I
might have to be more aggressive than
that person but any normal situation
dealing with human beings aggression
isn't a attribute it's a negative
because all it does is make people
defensive now listen it it doesn't mean
that you're sitting back in your
shirking and and shriveling up no but it
means that you're finding the balance
with another person and you're you're
working with them and conversing with
them to bring them along into your way
of thinking yeah that's what it is in in
you know when somebody asked me a
question like this it really signifies
to me that it makes me nervous because I
think to myself I say this all the time
I mean I say use the indirect approach
don't you know get people's defenses up
I say this all the time and yet someone
can still come back and say you know
people are telling me I'm being too
aggressive like they're not even taking
ownership of the fact that they're being
too aggressive right it's like the other
people are weak yeah and therefore since
they're weak they think I'm too
aggressive I can't believe how
they are yeah that's the reality that's
what's going through someone like this
mind like sometimes it's called working
on your how you know he's kind of saying
oh there they've got a euphemism for it
and and in the business world there's a
big push on diversity but it comes with
diversifying away from intensity and
male aggression I mean you can guarantee
what what this this guy thought I was
gonna say like no you got to just stay
the path you got it if people can't take
it
you gotta crush them yeah no no actually
that's the complete wrong answer yeah if
people can't take it it's because you
are being too aggressive you know the
way you're giving it is wrong the way
you're valent it is wrong so that
aggression needs to be channeled in such
a way that it's being utilized to
further the goal to further the goal and
you know who you get aggressive with
yourself you get aggressive with
yourself that's who I get aggressive
with you know I'm straightforward with
I'm straightforward with myself
that's who I'm straightforward with I'm
the one guy that I'm allowed to get
aggressive with to be straightforward
with to put things in to not sugarcoat
anything
I'm allowed to do that with me but I'm
not allowed to do it with another human
because it's not ineffective way of
leadership it just is not yeah it's it's
it's funny how like yeah that's
absolutely true
and and with you what I said is
absolutely I don't think I've ever seen
you get mad at someone else but at the
same at the same time and I think a lot
of people who may not know you good but
but have experience being around you
they all feel I would say that they'll
feel this same way and that is that yeah
fuckin chuckles cool or whatever but if
he were to like lose his temper on me
he'd probably die yeah good good
and they're right it's like I'm glad I'm
not losing my temper oh yeah yeah yeah
that will be good at all yeah that'd be
bad I have you know that would not be
good for people Donna I don't think
that's that cata me though right that is
that my sense of safety yet this sense
of impending doom is there at the same
time yeah yeah and and I think it I
think it does genuinely surprised people
yeah because I look like a serial killer
I'm a big guy whatever and they expect
that that I'm gonna be aggressive in
implementing this and you know you got
to get your shit together right but it's
just not it's just an ineffective way of
leadership if that was if that was
leadership leadership would be easy
right yeah I'm just gonna yell at
everyone there to do it I said you know
yeah I'm just gonna yell at everyone and
then they'll do what I say that just
does not work yeah it's crazy looks just
the way you talk a lot of the times not
all of them but just the way and maybe
it's like just how you saw I don't know
your voice I don't know it's probably
everything really is you do sound
intense even though you're not being
intense you know you just kind of seem
that way for all these reasons of course
well it's like you said earlier when I'm
talking about something that I care
about yes I am definitely going to be
intense about it especially when it's
something that is impactful to me yeah
and and something that means something
to me and to me leadership does mean a
lot to me yeah and and trying to help
people lead yeah is an important thing
to me I enjoy it and I like to see
people succeed so therefore when I talk
about it sometimes I get a little bit
fired up and I get intense with what I'm
saying that is it scary that just kinda
it's like indirectly scary so it's not
let me scare you okay I'll just I'll use
words scary it's indirectly scary where
when you do it's like oh I'm not scared
of what you're doing but you kind of
can't imagine and you're like all right
what if you know you're kind of like
you're like this raging hurricane that
when it comes by it turns into like a
warm gentle breeze
you know they kind of like and maybe
that's uh that's probably part of the
advantage ya heart of the advantages
people you know I said this I think it
was Tim Ferriss I said this too you know
people are surprised when I can sit
there and have a conversation with them
and I'm not aggressive with them and my
mind is open to what they're saying yeah
that's part of the game yeah